And I apologize in advance,
for your ears, I'm not a singer.
Oh, I like it already.
♪ Walking down the street ♪
♪ I'm hoping to run into you
and I do ♪
♪ But you've killed yourself ♪
This is embarrassing.
♪ When people describe you
they'll often just say dead ♪
♪ But to me you'll always be ♪
♪ Steingarten comma Ned ♪
9-1-1 OPERATOR (OVER PHONE)
911, what's your emergency?
BILLIE (OVER PHONE)
A man died and he's dead!
♪ In the night I miss you ♪
It's not my--
♪ I call out your name ♪
BILLIE (OVER PHONE) We need an
ambulance with a coffin!
It's not my voice.
♪ If you hadn't have jumped
well I'd still feel the same ♪
Just sounds like me,
it's not me.
BILLIE (OVER PHONE)
My name is Billie Brown!
My hair is blonde, no, no...
honey blonde!
Why do I keep describing
my hair so much?
♪ I will never forget you ♪
BILLIE (OVER PHONE)
I don't know his name!
This is not really happening.
It's not really--
You know what makes me laugh,
Billie?
You're exactly like Ned.
I'm not him. I'm not him.
You have his face, his glasses,
his hair.
And his job!
Hey, Billie, you're Ned.
What are you talking about?
I'm not Ned.
I'm Billie.
Why are you laughing at me?
You're Ned!
You're wrong.
No! Please, no!
♪ Steingarten comma Ned ♪
♪ No middle name I believe ♪
Thank you.
No! Don't do that!
Don't clap! Don't-- for her!
Why? A man died, and she's just
up here like...
Oh, “boo hoo" song--
I didn't cry.
I did.
You're both wearing denim
jackets to a memorial.
And you're all clapping away,
clapping away!
It was really just the coffee
guy clapping.
Oh, was it, Mr. Bigshot,
head of the department?
BFF's!
You know what, just fire me?
No, don't fire her.
I'm not gonna fire her.
I can't fire someone for doing
a bad Popeye imitation...
in a dead man's office.
Mediocre. And how did you
become friends with my boss?
Best friends.
She totally reminds me of Ned.
What did you just say?
Uh, I--
I am my own person!
Okay?
And this is whack! All right?
Y'all havin' a whack attack.
What?
Okay?
I need you to have some
russ-prect!
Okay, well, you just said...
"russ-prect".
For the dead!
I think we should leave.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I have a thing with funerals.
Okay, I'm getting her out.
It just always happens.
Problem is leaving.
I'm normal. I can be normal!
No one says, "I'm normal,"
who's normal.
Someone get my Yamaha.